man I got a question for you you know
many as we just saw the late night host
talking about how there needs to be more
gun control but when you look at what
they found in the car of this guy that
ammonium nitrate you just had the fuel
oil to it you've got an Oklahoma City
bomb there as well what gun control law
would have stopped that guy from doing
what he did back there I mean even the
guns that he was using I'm not sure that
there's any evidence that that gun
control would have done anything I mean
he obtained apparently these weapons
legally he had gone through federal
background checks there's no evidence of
significant mental illness to this point
so all this seems like his people
shouting do something while they have no
particular solutions and no expertise on
guns or gun control I mean the
suggestion that gun control is going to
put an end to incidents like this again
that is an evidence less proposition
based on nothing but emotional response
I was looking at Jimmy Kimmel last night
and he said well for those of you on
television all day that tell me not to
the not to talk about gun control my
First Amendment is just important as
your second Amendment Ben what's your
reaction to that I mean no one is
talking about stopping him from from
talking I mean I would I would never try
to ban Jimmy came home from talking on
television he should stop trying to ban
me from owning a firearm and again
noting that the late night hosts are
saying has any sort of relationship to
reality if they want to call for an
outright gun ban if they want to call
for all guns in the United States to be
removed then we can at least get an
honest assessment of what it is they
believe but when they say things like a
little bit of common-sense gun control
would stop all of this that's that's
just a chimera it's not true they're
making things up because this is all
about the moral disapproval of people
who own guns and that that's what drips
from a lot of these folks is this idea
that if you oppose them on policy it's
because you don't care enough about what
happened in Las Vegas and that really is
that that's quite disgusting I mean the
idea that if we disagree on politics
it's because my heart isn't big enough
but your heart is just big enough so you
understand Jimmy Kimmel or Stephen
Colbert or Seth Meyers
you understand truly what America needs
because you care so much that's that's
pretty nasty stuff so what is the issue
here what do we need to be talking about
well I mean I think we don't have enough
information yet to know what sort of
policy proposals would would be on the
table that the sample size is so low
because it
to be non-representative of deaths
involving guns in the united states
overall for a variety of reasons I mean
if we actually want to talk about gun
violence across the United States we'd
actually have to start talking about if
you're gonna talk to uncontrol then
let's talk about democratic areas in
major cities because that's where
virtually all of the murder this is a
huge percentage of the murder is taking
place in the United States even that
though it would be I think false premise
because the fact is that the number of
guns in the United States has gone up as
the murder rate has gone down per capita
there now one point four or five guns
per American in the United States there
were less than one gun for Americans in
the in the United States in 1993 and the
murder rate has declined markedly since
that time so the idea that more guns
equals more crime or more guns
invariably equals more mass shooting the
evidence is really weak on this stuff
yeah so what does that tell you does
that tell you that more people owning
guns with murder rates going down is it
because we feel like using a gun we can
protect ourselves more owning a gun I
mean I think there's a case to be made
for that the truth is that correlation
in these cases doesn't always equal
causation so saying more guns less crime
it may be just as wrong as saying less
guns more crime but by the same token to
suggest that if we just remove guns
that's going to send the crime rate down
it's not true people keep talking about
things like Australia where there's a
big gun buyback and the fact is that in
Australia they only removed one third
and one fifth of guns the gun crime rate
was declining markedly before that and
the United States is not the same as
Australia try going to Texas and telling
everybody they need to hand their guns
over to the federal government and see
how the gun rate right it doesn't that
very good that I also tell the people in
England how safe they are when they've
had five attacks over the last year well
then they have very few guns over there
as well as as well as Spain true good
point Ainsley and finally I didn't know
I'm not a gun guy don't pretend to be
but now I'm finding about these bump
fire these bump fire stocks that allow
us semi automatic to be an automatic and
the fact is according to the ATF it was
actually illegal to do would you as a
pro-gun guy entertain the fact that we
get rid of some of that conversion yeah
I think I would I mean the fact is the
machine guns have been illegal for sale
since 1986 in the United States devices
that can convert a semi-auto to fire
like an auto I think there's pretty
widespread support for getting rid of
some of these device
that said bump stock is very easy to
make yourself to imitate firing a
semi-auto at a high rate is not
particularly difficult to train to do so
I think that we can do it I just I
wouldn't use it as this sort of the this
pen Asia I don't think that you can use
it as a cure-all and the idea that that
would cure these problems the vast
majority of mass shootings have not
taken place with automatic weapons or
even semi autos being fired like autos
they've been with semi-automatic rifles
or mostly with handguns